you uh
you're the co-founder of just like we've
been talking about axion systems
uh yeah this is would you say space
propulsion company
yes broadly speaking um so
uh how do you big question how do you uh
build a rocket company from like
a propulsion company from one person
from two people
to ten people plus and actually
you know take it to a successful product
yeah well i think the early stage is
quite
uh i'm not supposed to use the word easy
when you work in rocket science but
straightforward um when you're working
on something you know sexy like an ion
engine
it's more straightforward to raise money
and and get people to come
work for you because the vision is
really exciting and actually that's
something i would say is very important
throughout is
a really exciting vision because when
everything
you know goes to crap you need that to
get people
getting themselves out of bed in the
morning and thinking of the
the higher purpose there um and
you know another thing along the way
that i think is key in
in building any company is
the right early employees that also have
their own
networks and can bring in um a lot of
people that
um you know really make the
this the whole greater than than just
the sum of the early team
yeah how do you build that like how do
you find people it's like asking
like how do you make friends but is
there um
is it a is it luck is there a system
like how in terms of the people you've
connected with the
the people you built the company with
is there some thread some commonality
some pattern
that you find it to be to hold for what
makes a great team
uh i think you know personally a thread
for me
has been my network and
being able to draw on that a lot but
also
giving back to it as much as possible in
like an unsolicited sort of way like
making
connections between people that you know
maybe didn't ask but that
i think could be really fruitful and um
even you know weirder than that is just
really
getting you know having weird
uncomfortable conversations with people
like at a conference and getting
over the small talk quickly and getting
to know them quickly
and having a relationship that stands
out and then being able to call on them
later because of that and i think that's
it's
that's been because i'm introverted and
i
you know want to poke my eyes out
instead of go and do small
talk and so i huddle in a corner with
one person
and you know we talk about aliens or
things like that and
um so you know that's all to say that
you know having a strong network
i think is really important but a
genuine one
and let's see other ways to build a
rocket company
kind of making sure you're paying
attention to the sweeping trends of the
industry so everybody just cares about
cost and um being able to get out
ahead of that and even more than we ever
thought we'd need to as far as
what we needed to price our systems at
you know people
for since the start of the the u.s space
industry they've been paying
20 25 million in adjusted dollars for an
ion engine and
seeing that now people are going to want
to pay
10k for an ion engine um
and just staying out ahead of that and
those kinds of things
um so you know being out in the industry
and and talking to as many people as
possible so there's a drive
i mean yeah spacex really pushed that
frustrating for me
yeah so uh spacex really pushed this
uh yeah the application of uh i guess
capitalism of driving the price down
of um basically forcing people to ask
the question can be
this can this be done cheaper
this can lead to
like big problems i would say in in the
following sense
i see this in the car industry for
example
that uh people have
it's such a small margin
for profit like they've driven the cost
of everything down so much
that there's literally no room for
innovation taking risks
so like cars which is funny
because not until tesla really which is
one of
the in a long long time one of the first
successful new car companies that's
constantly innovating
every other car company is really
pouring in terms of their technological
innovation
they innovate on design and style and so
on
that you that people fall in love with
the look and so on but it's not really
innovation
the in terms of the technology and it's
really boringly the same thing and
they're really afraid to have taken
risks
and that's a big problem for rocket
space too is like
you if you're cutting on costs you can't
afford to innovate to try out new things
and then
yeah that's definitely true with i ion
engine then right
uh so but what um so how do you compete
in this
uh in this space do you by the way see
spacex as a competitor
and what do you say in general about the
competition in the space is it
really difficult as a as a business to
compete here
no i i don't see spacex as a competitor
and i see them as one day not too long
from now
a customer hopefully um
i mean to compete against that i think
you just have to do things in an
unconventional way so
bringing silicon mems manufacturing to
propulsion you know
nasa doesn't make ion engines using a
batch mass producible technique they
have you know
one guy that's been making their ion
engines for 20 years like
bespoke pieces of jewelry so
bringing things to what you're trying to
innovate to
to make them you know in our case more
cost effective was
was really key i like the idea of uh
somebody putting out ion engines on like
etsy yeah
my um advisor at mit would you know the
thruster chip i was holding up he would
wear one as a lapel
pin
you